I'm here to tell you the Rihanna there
she be in 2007 was awarded the title of
celebrity legs of a goddess weren't you
it made its own all fancy I just did a
deal with Gillette
[Laughter]
Briana's our fish has the best legs in
the world because of us yeah they didn't
show my legs your legs easy so it's kind
of a thesaurus egg they're beautiful
legs but a bit hairier didn't you have a
weird a weird recognition thing when you
were having hair removal you don't
somewhere I talked to that much so you
were having big stuff hair removal hair
removal and they recognized you down
there
[Applause]
I know this
[Applause]
okay so I was well I went to this wax
salon and I she recognized me before it
took my clothes off and I think she just
wanted she couldn't wait until we were
alone so she could just ask for an
autograph or something you know
something like that
okay the autograph and then um you know
obviously I'm laying there and in pain
and she just decides to bust though and
you know every time I get a wax
I always specify that the lady is old
and speaks Russian or no English and she
was 25 was 25 year old American and she
was basically like I know who you are
you're a Rihanna aren't you I was just
like awkward the most awkward moments of
my entire life
I just got up and I just got out of
there CR do not ever bring me back here
told you old and Russian well thank you
for sharing that story thank you very
much
project senior bottom or not what would
you like to know I think I probably I
mean it can't be an actress not see a
boss like I said I read you had a stunt
bottom I stunt bottom on Elizabeth was
that well I did ask for an upgrade I
said look at you my bosom let's get a
better one
how did you meet the lady the bottom yes
I don't know whether it was my bottom or
her bottom in the end I didn't really
look that closely but you don't see your
own bottom very often - so how would I
know but wait did you like it
I didn't really I mean I don't do if you
would you know while you're looking at
her bottom I'd look at your budget you
beat Meryl which is like that's a good
double win because that gets competitive
it does between the people not between
the people Studios have to do the whole
rounds of all the different workshops
can you see yes
so what was the award show where you you
locked lips what do you mean where she
asked for it
did you actually beg you she what the
the backstory which no and they're like
why did you go and kiss Meryl I go well
who wouldn't want to kiss Meryl
but she was egging me on this entire
time like she's heckling she's like you
know she sent to my office I go oh my
god Meryl Streep sent you flowers like
round strips that me flowers and up
comes this this nice bottom part with
like three dead orchids on it
that's a die [ __ ]
that is classic I like it was it was
no-holds-barred I had I had to take
barrel down I didn't I kissed her I
figured like if I was gonna humiliate
her kill her with kindness kill her with
my kisses no no I'm wait you really like
look at that look at the case what was
the evidence to kiss was you Fredo
[Laughter]
in the background was the thing is
you'll be flicking channels and see this
and nobody didn't know who you but in a
year's time when he's the next Superman
[Laughter]
they send you things they do so many
things
I'm absolutely crap it answering him he
was brought in a piece that I did bring
that somebody said anything I've read in
the last week I apologize to anybody who
sent me something but I did it's very
nicely done yes beautiful that affair
has made this it's called 25 things
Helena Bonham Carter has taught me and
it's things like you know the best
outfits don't have to match very nice
difference is good always we choose
yourself follow your heart and don't
start bursting like I'm doing a service
I feel better that's nice until number
17 and then get down 17 what hellevang
Carter's taught me that it's okay to
have short thick legs
[Applause]
all the way on my friend dollar so like
just me don't make me feel good I said
like yeah actually hadn't read it all I
said like okay and then I did now I've
obviously you know but maybe do you
think she means that I have ones or
maybe I'm making her feel okay about
hers let's go with that I think you made
shorts a Clegg's
fashionable then I've done something
really helpful do you think
[Applause]
[Music]